welcome back we are all invited to play
golf and poker this weekend for a great
cause let's check back in with rocky at
the charity series of poker headquarters
to learn how las vegas is going against
all odds for saint jude hi rocky
hey mercedes and jillian all right you
guys ready
show your hands did i say that right
show your hands
boom okay
matt poker pro how did we do who won uh
surprisingly i won with a pair of kings
here wait a minute i believe that
happened that's so weird it's so weird
all right fine whatever whatever but i
know you've been waiting to go all in so
go ahead everybody push their push their
chips in
we're going all in for st jews um so if
you know for example you did win this
tournament what are you winning this
weekend at the tournament you're winning
a 10 000 seat to the world series poker
main event where you can win eight
million or more
wow
okay so
so their actual seat is in the
tournament yep you get to play on the
world stage in the biggest poker
tournament of the year that is
incredible and of course you guys if
you're out there you don't have to be a
poker pro to sign up for the against all
odds poker tournament so let's turn over
to erica now with st jude's um just tell
us what this means to the organization
and how people can sign up so the
proceeds are going to help us find cures
and save children so saint jude is
treating children with
childhood cancer and other
life-threatening diseases and we are
very dependent on our supporters to help
us ensure families never receive a bill
from saint jude of course okay wow well
that is you don't need to hear a thing
another thing in order to go ahead and
sign up and again how do you sign up do
you own our website yeah the website is
st jude against all odds dot org and
that's st.org
just really quick you know what's the
vibe like at the tournament is this such
a really fun event yeah i mean it's it's
about the most fun any of us ever get to
have playing poker it's got a whole bit
home game feel even when we have some of
the best players in the world coming out
and supporting these causes they're
they're drinking they're having a good
time they're teaching people at their
table how to play we've never played
before it's it's a really fun event even
if you haven't played much like like
myself you know i thought i would learn
a little something or two here but you
know we're just been having fun i i
guess you know i learned that you gotta
wear visors and glasses that's the vibe
you gotta look serious i'll send it back
to you guys
thank you rocky that looks like so much
fun how are you when it comes to playing
poker you know for fun i'm okay but if
everyone was watching me i think i would
be too nervous i definitely want the
glasses on